i think it's important to try out loads
of different strategies as well to kind
of find what fits you because everyone
has a different
strategy in mind that works for them the
best and if you haven't tried a few
different ones then you don't know
what's really going to work for you
there's a lot of people that speak about
sort of lease options and rent to rent
but they've never actually done it
they might speak bad a bit but they've
never actually had the experience
themselves i know
and it's just it's it's don't talk about
something
you've not done like serious yeah i mean
it's just it's painful to see it and it
happens and and when you see people
saying
and and the thing is people some people
say it can't be done because i've never
done it or because they tried and failed
yeah
you know but but if you haven't got
first-hand experience of something don't
talk about it
i said to you you're asking me some
questions about social housing and stuff
and i said a lot
i have got i've even got properties
myself you know that i've put with
housing associations accounts
direct i don't talk about it because i
don't deal with it my wife deals with it
yeah it's not my
thing yeah it's not your area no you
know more than i know about it i'm sure
because it's your back that's what
you've really
and i know you started in your journey
but you know you did some
my videos i don't you did you ever do
the crash course so that's one thing so
like kind of coming off of the thing
where people talk about it like a
strategy and stuff before
like going on board and doing it
themselves is the same thing with like
the crash course
like i hadn't actually come on the crash
course because people had told me not to
go like oh it's like
you know with like every property
training program like everyone's always
kind of like oh it's just a
sales pitch and all this and all that
and i regret not coming on the crash
course because i think i would have been
a lot more successful a lot earlier
yeah if i'd actually come and got the
training instead of just learning purely
off the videos
yeah um so people say that are absolute
morons because the crash course is the
best property training program in my
opinion on the planet yeah and it's free
yeah it's free to knock i mean even for
the networking if you're
if you're if you're so worried about
something
you know being hypnotized into buying
something come on get real
i mean it's just ridiculous but yeah
people people
people try and tell you not to do
something whether it's a course or a
property strategy
or property at all don't go into
property because it's risky well hang on
a minute
why would i listen to you when you're
working for 70 hours a week for
and you're on 26 000 pounds a year and
you're miserable yeah and
you just look forward to the weekends
yeah like what would i take advice from
another thing that you mentioned there
as well as about the networking side of
things
so even if you don't come away from like
moving on to like a full-time course
with yourself or with anyone
regardless of what the course it is
you've got that network in there so
you've got people who are other
investors you've got other people who
might be doing different types of
property trades whether it's
builders accountants whatever it is
yeah networking's vital yeah i think
getting environment
getting around people that are winning
yeah and i think it's
it's so important to surround yourself
with people where success feels normal
because i believe the environment is
stronger than willpower if you're trying
to set yourself up on your own
you're just going to keep pinging back
to your old habits your old routines but
if you're around winners if you're
around people that are
financially independent you know have a
good financial literacy
then that's going to rub off on you
exactly yeah so obviously we touched on
your
um stop the start of your journey um and
obviously leveraging the people around
you
to you know get into the property ladder
um how did you manage to go
from starting off with one property to
then working on developments do you want
to just kind of like give us a breakdown
yeah sure so i mean developments came a
lot later
it depends how to find developments i
mean technically my first house in 2009
was a mini development because i
converted it into hmo and we financed it
yeah but but it wasn't a development
like you'd probably be referring to in
terms of
some of the stuff i'm working on now
yeah um
so deal packaging was the thing that
really made me wealthy
everyone always says i've noticed that
with every successful person that i've
spoken to that's gotten the experience
that's gotten to this point
yeah has always started off with deal
packaging yeah well i didn't start with
deal packaging
i actually became financially free um i
built up you know double digit portfolio
of my own first
yeah and it's funny because deal
packaging i won't be so arrogant to say
i created it
but at the time when i started ideal
packaging it wasn't a thing yeah like no
one was talking about it no one was
doing it
um how that happened i'll tell you so
when i left bible college
i was about to get married i was doing
quite well i was making about six and a
half thousand pounds a month passive
from my properties
i built up with joint ventures and lease
options and raised finance that was cool
highly leveraged i was probably worth
about
half a million pounds if you if you
added up everything and you saw it i've
been with half a million pounds yeah
and i was 23. i was doing okay yeah
working class
yeah i was doing good yeah right that
was about six years ago
but the thing is i'd love that to pay
people back had money that
i owed people yeah i was thinking oh to
be fair that's going to take me a
potential long time in rent unless i
happen to be able to refinance
okay so i might have to refinance i got
a bit of money to pay back
yeah i was getting married i wanted to
have a decent wedding
um and i thought actually you know what
if i'm not careful
i might run out of cash yeah i'm not
doing great
yeah i'm actually not doing great i'm
people might think i'm doing great but
actually
i'm not i don't have to not worry about
money
because actually six hundred thousand
pound a month is okay all the time
you want to do a wedding it all adds up
yeah you want to stop
doing this that the other i i was
setting up a charity i was going out to
africa
yeah zimbabwe zambia and i really wanted
to
give something i'm actually i'm okay for
myself as a single man but if i want to
start getting married having kids
and setting up charities doing stuff i'm
actually not in a i'm not rich
yeah so i wanted to start making some
serious money
and i thought right i'm gonna stop
there's a couple of houses that i'd
viewed i wanted to buy that i
couldn't afford to buy i didn't have the
money i was like oh man what can i do
so i thought i know what i'll do what
i'll do is i'll go out
and i will view a bunch of houses but
are offered to bring someone with me so
hey if you want to come with me and
spend the day with me
any houses i thought my houses are so
good my investments have lined up i've
got great relationships with the agents
so i thought anyone that wants to go
ahead and buy if this person wants to
buy one of the properties yeah they can
buy it but they have to pay me a
thousand pounds
yeah so here was the proposition this
was technically deal sourcing before i
knew deal sourcing was a thing yeah
proposition was hey
next tuesday i'm spending the day in
liverpool i'm viewing seven houses
my intention is to buy one for myself
yep if you want to come with me and
spend the day with me
it's free come with me if you want to
buy one of the other six
right which you will yeah you got to
give me a grant
were these deals through estate agents
or were they like off marketing mostly
through stages
but well both there were stages but off
market as well yeah a lot of them were
because i was in i even became the stage
just to make friends yeah so
some of them might be a case of i got
i've just got the keys it's not a right
move yet
yeah but mostly through estate agents
yeah yeah and i believe you can get
really good deals directions they're the
golden nuggets i think so because
an agent wouldn't you know take on a
property unless it was worthwhile
um so i think if you're able to get by
like you said before it's even hit the
super
right move yeah and yeah there's great
good opportunities there exactly
so so i'd speak to some investors they'd
come out with me in the day for the car
i'm in the car
and i'd be like i want that one and then
they'd be oh i love that one and then i
go no problem give them my grand they
give me a grand and then go and buy it
that's how it rolled
as time progressed i started bringing
two people with me
i'd line up ten houses three people four
people
and it got to the point where there
wouldn't be enough deals for the people
and then i thought actually you know
what forget bringing anyone with me
i'll go out myself yeah i'll offer and
i'll package them up and then i'll send
an email actually
to this list yeah and then the first
time i sent an email i made six and a
half thousand pounds
and i sold three houses all in one night
and i hadn't even spent a day with
anybody and i was like
wow that was around about 2014.
okay i thought wow yeah maybe early
2015. i can't remember exactly but it
was around that time i thought wow
this is interesting i then went into
packaging and sell 200 deals i made
um a half a million pounds doing that
yeah that made me a millionaire
yeah because i was already worth a few
hundred pounds put the money into
property that might be a millionaire
and um it also grew me
a massive list of investors and money's
in the list
yeah then i started joint venturing with
the investors you know so
and sort of snowballing it so how did i
get into development to answer your
question
i think it was as i got more money yeah
as i got more investors and more money
i started looking for bigger deals yeah